signs of life in downtown las vegas as
local shops experience a big boost in
business
yeah brian some say this is the most
foot traffic they've had in over a year
reporter kate houston went to the arts
district to see how
business owners are reacting it's a nice
day we've had a ton of people come in we
had a really big surge of business
packed parking spots and full tables a
welcome sign of normalcy in downtown las
vegas
right now we have quite a few names on
the wait list whether it's a monday
thursday tuesday a lot of people coming
down
amina todd with makers and finders says
there was a 20 person wait list
wednesday morning
this surge in visitors has been
happening for weeks
and other business owners like derrick
stonebarger with rebar
are experiencing it as well it's been
wild it's been
it feels like it's a pre-pandemic our
numbers are maybe even slightly higher
than they were before we went into this
the boost could be due to vaccinations
and pent up energy
as well as efforts to make it safer and
more appealing in downtown
the city of las vegas is placing banners
in key districts near downtown like
restaurant row on carson avenue
to help bring in more people other
projects such as the gateway arches and
road work on las vegas boulevard
are an effort to beautify the area it
doesn't even feel like vegas to me i
feel like i'm in austin or
l.a or different i don't know it just
seems like a totally different idea of
what you know you think of when you
think of vegas now local businesses are
hoping to keep this momentum going and
are preparing for the first
in-person first friday in over a year
it's exciting to know
that that when people are coming back
when they're actually coming out for the
first place that they want to eat or
drink
or celebrate with their friends a small
group of friends is
down here in the arts district kate
houston 8 news now
people are ready to get out again well
downtown businesses are expecting a big
crowd during
first friday that's going to happen this
coming friday april 2nd
due to safety guidelines only 250 people
though are allowed on the actual art
walk at a time